hello
foreign
you know
can you hear me
all right yeah hello
hi is that pain
hi hi
okay glad you could join
I just uh
okay Fernando is here too
yes uh yeah sorry we had a connection
issue no no worries
um
Okay so
oh hi hi uh Fernanda
hello Miss hi good
great good to see you
um
so let's see um let me just make sure
that the
other panelists I have to enter and then
uh
a um do you want to make sure you can
you can share your slides
oh yeah
[Music]
you are
um
yeah very good
okay
together
um so should we start or should we wait
for a few more minutes uh let's just
wait for a minute I just want to make
sure that uh
uh that I'm not missing somebody on the
um okay okay okay okay yes sure
we should start in a minute or so let me
just
uh
okay I think it's fine you can
be so
um
okay so so let's um let's start uh it's
real pleasure to have a paper here uh
who will talk about his uh recent
breakthrough with Fernando uh uh
Geronimo from they're both from is
um uh okay so I think that there's a
there's a lot of uh this is a very
interesting
um talk it's a it's a very interesting
result uh both for what it achieves and
what it promises in the future I think
that's that's been fair to fair to say
and
um
um yeah it's uh I I guess uh I guess
it's a particularly nice time to get a
result pay because
um I I assume you're now going on the
job market soon or already on it so so
wish you luck with that and really
looking forward to your talk so please
thank you mesh yes uh so first thank you
for the invitation thank you for
providing us this opportunity to share
our result uh it's a great pleasure
and now uh
the art
[Music]
okay so in this box we are going to talk
about the quantum money rsms and the
title is the power of entangled Quantum
proofs with non-native amplitudes
um so maybe let's first start with uh
some basic definition about Quantum
learning answer group system so in this
system we have uh the all powerful
murdering and uh our friend arson
is facing some card problem for example
uh three color sorry okay all right so
I'm still seeing your title slide
ah ah okay uh let's see uh maybe I
should not use the presentation mode
um
now uh are you seeing this uh slide yes
okay okay
yeah okay maybe let me not use a
presentation mode
um okay yeah
so uh okay we have uh yeah in the in the
quantum learning officer group system we
have the all-power for Learning and our
friend after and our sir is facing a
heart problem like here are the three
colors
uh problem uh he wants to know whether a
given graph is three colorable or not
so he seeks help from learning and
Merlin will stand him upon Emily size
Quantum proof
and there is and for our sir he does not
know whether he should believe Merlin or
not so he will do some pqp computation
on the proof UCS and makes a measurement
in the end he decides whether
this graph is recaliburable or not so
the correctness Criterium is that
whenever this uh graph instance is
recallable then the benign learning
should be able to convince us with a
good probability C
and on the other hand if this graph
instance has no valid three coloring
then there should be no adversary
learning that can co-author with a
larger probability so say s
and what do we carry is that the gap
between these two probabilities e minus
s we are good as long as this Gap is
some constant
okay
okay a very natural generalization of
the about model is where we have like
multiple learning so say just two merely
uh so now like if us are facing
um this heart problem what he will do is
uh he asks the two marines to send game
approved and it's important that these
two neurons in the two learnings there
are no entanglement
and then after receiving uh two groups
our sir again doing some pqp time uh
verification and decides whether to
accept or not
and the criteria the correctness
Criterion would be uh very similar so in
the yes case uh Oster should accept to
raise a large probability and in no case
Arthur will not be fooled by a large
probability and again the gaps should be
a constant
so uh
this model is uh is interesting besides
that it is a natural model
from the complexity perspective
for persistence it is also like
interesting because it provides a very
natural model to study this fundamental
uh phenomenon of quantum entanglement
um
so another reason uh is like it's a very
interesting optimization problem
so for example if you think about qma
with one burning then like underlying is
a problem that's to compute to the
eigenvalue of some emission matrices
associated with the computation doing by
faster
and now when we have two marines it
corresponds to some optimization
problems that is to optimize over
the states that tends to protect of unit
vectors
so that's another reason why it's
interesting
well for computer scientists uh very
natural question to ask is just to like
uh what is the computational power
captured by this model
so maybe first what is the relationship
between two marines and Walmart
um so it's clear that uh when you have
tumorings you have more power
because RCA can simply ignore warm
learning and just uh interact with the
first learning for example
so this would be a trivial overbound
and what kind of upper bounds we can put
for this qma2 model
well uh
it is contained in next
non-deterministic exponential type
this is because Arthur can just guess
the classical description of what the
tumor links would stand that's like
especially many amplitude
and then also can just do the classical
simulation of bqp
and in total it's gonna be a content in
next
so these are like the trivial bounds we
can
explain in 30 minutes in 30 seconds
and somehow there actually all we know
essentially all we know about this
complexity cross qma2
okay
uh any question
now very naturally you would ask uh what
about uh if we have three main sperm
earnings
Etc uh do we like have more power
do we form some hierarchy uh
so this we actually understand in fact
we can always reduce the number of
Martins to just two
and this is due to uh this famous result
uh by Hiro and Maldonado so they
analyzed the product test
so in particular this task this test is
designed for the following task
to give you a copies of give us the apsi
and do you want to know whether this
date is a product state
a tensor of
a different uh state
product test
uh would be the following
if you have two copies of the State per
se so you would just apply the swap test
to the first subsystem to the second
subsystem
Etc to the cases to the case subsystem
and note that if your state precise
indeed the product state
and then all the swap tests should
accept
and Converse uh and what had random did
is to analysis uh the converged case in
particular they show that if your state
PSI
is like Epsilon far away from a product
date from any product state
then the product test
will reject with the probability that's
set to Absolute
so using this product test
you can actually show that I can reduce
the number of fluvers
for arbitrary large to just K and the
cost of increasing the length of your
proof sorry okay uh in this are you are
you applying the product uh sequentially
a month for each uh register or are you
doing it
uh no no we so we are we are applying
the swap test question on each subsystem
yeah let's see question yes thank you
yeah
uh okay uh any other questions
[Music]
what is swap test okay uh
a swapped test uh wealth and see how
should Target the best way to Islam yes
so basically swap test is like a test
that helps you to decide whether to
States on Tango state are equal or not
uh
uh yeah so maybe just to say that yeah
you can take it off
yeah okay okay yes yes so maybe uh we
were our answer in more detail are
playing
uh okay yeah so maybe let's very briefly
see uh how to use the product test to
help us reduce the number of uh the
approvers
the basic idea is just uh we were asked
the two Proverbs to simulate uh the cape
group but by requiring that each prover
sent what the k-provers should say
and then after we're applying one of the
following test the product test or just
the original uh verification procedure
for k-provers
on either proof uh from the two programs
so let's consider uh like the
complainer's case so which that is like
trivial
we don't need to uh do anything and on
the other hand for the standards case
so a bad a bad murdering if he wants to
a full author he either send uh states
that far from a product state which will
be detected by product test or he will
send something that close to a product
test but then in that case just by the
soundness of the original uh
uh ma K product codes uh the
verification should detect that
any question
okay okay so these are like classical
results
uh yeah
and at this point we kind of uh
discussed like uh multiple approvers and
the question now is like how can we uh
how we how do we understand the case
when there are only two proofers and as
I mentioned that uh we said we know
essentially nothing except the trivial
bound
uh but at like a final uh level
we know something better we know like
Uma with two mirrorings uh it could be
more powerful than while murdering and
there are like several results uh
including this below tabs protocol which
I'm gonna explain
and also like Scott Aronson's result
[Music]
but maybe now let me just explain uh
what do I mean
so first let's just look at the pillar
tabs protocol for the Greek
problems
okay so now we have uh three colors
and Merlin wants to help Arthur to
determine whether it's uh it's
recolorable or not
what learning should send uh
in the yes case he should just tell
Arthur
the colors
for each vertex and they do have been
coded in this way the uniform
odds or not
and then their color
now Arthur upon receiving such proof so
there will be a multiple approved
as we already think that
k-provers and two Proverbs are the same
so like in the following of the talk we
were basically assumed a lot of
learnings without explicit explaining it
but here we only uh let's think that
there are only oh no
and for Simplicity we will assume that
the two proofs are are actually equal so
which you can achieve by doing the swap
test
and then what Passover do is he will
make measurements
two states
uh just with respect to the
computational basis
so what the author could observe
so he will observed some uh vertices
and their color
in the case that the two measurements
uh
the send vertex then we should expect
that we observe to we should expect to
observe consistent color
um I think I'll expand in more detail
why this why we want this
and on the other hand if
we see like
two verses and in the case that the
adjacent then we should expect they to
have distinct colors
and this is exactly the case like if the
learning is Facebook and the graph
instance is very colorful now on the
other hand if the instance is not three
colorable and let's for now assume that
the murdering is based for actually he
sends some
coding of the coloring
then what will happen is uh
author like with certain probability
will find
some age
that is not satisfy this distinct color
constraint
probability is like one over poly n
okay now an obvious issue with this with
what we talked so far is that submarine
can just descend like uh
a partial assignment to the graph so he
can find like a subset of the graph that
is recallable and he just signed that
part to answer and all these
will be satisfied
so what is missing is that authors
should also check that in fact the proof
sent by Merlin in codes uh
all the colors
for all the vertices
and to do so
we just uh note first
because of this cons that if the sample
text is observed then we should also
appear in color
this is kind of saying that for a
typical uh
for typical vertex that there is a
unique color
but inside this state so it's you don't
have a superposition of
typical vertex
and because of this uh what we want to
do is just
disentangle the first register and the
second register and come
the uniform superposition of all the
vertices
so this is a shield
all in all uh Bavarian tabs protocol
tell us that for this MP hard problem MP
complete problem
it can't be solved using two
merlings
and with only logarithmic size
of quantum proofs
and one
in the completed case after always
accept
and in the sound case parser will reject
with probability one minus one over
oh yeah
but this I hope one lower poly end Gap
binomial small Gap is not ideal for us
sense that in our definition of
customers after games we want constant
Gap and for example if you want to prove
say next is starting
uma2 which would be the most ideal
situation
we would want the constant Gap but when
we scale this result easily we get
exponentially small Gap that's something
we cannot afford
and you feel
yeah
I'm sorry it's not it's not clear how
did you compare the two superpositions
how did you
how did you remove the color there
okay okay here uh being yes here I'm
being unclear so you can just uh so
assume okay uh assume like for a typical
uh
there is only one color then what you
can do is you just do the Fourier
transport for example to the second
register and you measure it and you want
to see a zero and when it is
you will compare it with the Unicorn
superposition
okay so you're willing to to take
polynomial losses in efficiency
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean like uh we
don't we do not want to but uh yes there
are other like button next yes okay
uh okay thanks for the question
uh yeah okay
so as as we see that we incurred this on
this polynomial small Gap and it kind of
comes from this the measurement
part
like it is uh in this particle we are
only using some very local information
from
and we are not treating this proof in a
global Manner and that's kind of the
high level issue
here
so from now on let's uh
uh switch to like our model
um uh with non-nactive amplitudes which
our exponent
in a minute but our goal would to uh
would be to design Global protocols with
a constant Gap
like for uh
products more set expansion problem in
the game's problem constraint
satisfaction problem so an increasing uh
really harder and harder uh problems
and uh like for all these problems there
is some notion of expansion hidden there
and some real business on the definition
about these problems
and together with these properties and
our Assumption of non-nactivity we can
actually achieve like Global particles
and constant gaps
um so like we will start from the small
set expansion problem
which really captures like the Notions
of expansion and robustness it serves as
a very clean
illustrating examples for our result
okay
so let's first make sure that we are on
the same page about uh our new model so
the new in the new model we restrict the
learnings to send a proof
that's that the quantum State should
have non-negative amplitudes
so this is the case even in the sound is
uh situation so even uh adversarial
learning should send such proof okay
and with this restriction like
everything else would be the same as a
standard Quantum learning author game so
uh in the completed case
good Marines should convince our spirit
with high probability and in a Spanish
case no anniversary remote and can pull
us there with a high probability we just
need this Gap to be some constant an
arbitrary constant
okay uh any any questions about this
model
okay okay so now let's uh Define this
small set expansion problem if you
haven't seen it
before so this is a promise problem
um
we we are given some irregular graphs
there should exist uh a subset a small
set of the vertices
uh good size is about that time scan as
to the number versus delta is some
parameter that you should think of it as
some more constant like 10 of the total
versus
and what we require in the yes case is
that this
is non-expanding in the sense that all
the edges
touching a Vertex that as should
actually remain in test
in other words the HS that Crossing this
s and this complement
should be very very very small
uh like basically session you know and
just crossing this cut
so that's the yes case
and in the no case
we should require that all the small
are actually expanding
like any ages that actually touches s
so that
across this complementary card
so it may be a little bit confusing like
the yes case that it corresponds to
notice
okay test correspond to uh expanding
okay
because approximately equals to
this is
up to some like Delta prime or something
right like Delta and whatever the
content in the approximately equal to
are both like and independent contents
well they actually oh okay let's let's
just think it's uh
some independent constant
for for the purpose of this talk so here
I may be succinctly tests like Point uh
here you can think of it as like pointer
upper part 9. okay thanks
uh okay
okay now let's just test the uh
uh protocol uh in our model which we
call it q a plus q a plus
for this more set expansion problem
so in the yes case uh that is there
exists a small subset that's
non-expanding
and then what murdering
um should send is just the superposition
of the vertices
uh
an author we're receiving such proof so
again many copies of this proof and we
assume that these copies are all the
same
for Simplicity
and then also is going to use the fact
that this is a deregular graph
then it can be seen as a Assam or
permutations like here I draw this graph
a two regular graphs it's like two uh
permutations the clockwise notation and
anti-clockwise notation
and then after just take uh a random
permutation
from this perspective
and the permutation is good because it
can be implemented as a unitary operator
so we just applied applied this random
permutation
to the proof to one of the primer who
received from earning
and now let's see what happens
so in the yes case
because
that s is not expanding and it
essentially forms a connected component
on its own like this random permutation
like on average is just standing it's
just permuting Within
this subset s and therefore when we
permute when we when we append this
permuted uh state it should be the same
as almost the same as the original state
um
on the other hand
in no case
uh if Martin
uh form Superstition all this muscle
like because it's expanding
then this random permutation like on
average would Ascend the vertices from s
outside
s
so if you compare the Primitive version
with
date then they are actually uh
orthogonal
so like a swap test will detect these
two uh different cases with high
probability with constant probability
well the the issue that uh
like learning can actually send a super
a uniform superposition of all verses
and then by definition it is not
so we need to handle that case
and if we can handle that
then we actually show that there's a
small Set uh
expansion problem is content in
uh youma Class 2 and using logarithmic
size
Quantum proofs is constant cap
so maybe any questions
okay yeah sorry I I don't understand
something
um the uh this protocol like what what
is the what is Merlin proving is Merlin
proving that the test that that the
graph has small set expansion or that it
doesn't right if it's proving that it is
if he's proving that it has small set
expansion then you have to show that
this is true for every small set right
yes yes yes so I don't know what I can
do so yes yes this is this is confused
um because it's defined not in the most
natural way like in the yes case
there exists and bending subset uh right
the yes case there should exist a
non-expanding subset thank you so yeah
yeah
like in no case there's no uh all the
small steps should expand yeah
I see so this is so this is really like
a qma plus two protocol for co-sse
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
in this in your qma to protocol
business case
you don't know that there is a
non-expansia
um I'm sorry I think there's some noise
that uh I missed some
all right
she says never mind
uh okay sorry about it sure
um yeah but we can definitely uh discuss
more like offline
uh
uh okay so maybe uh go back
other questions
okay okay
well so uh so the missing part is like
the sparsity test we want to uh we want
to make sure that what we received by
learning actually uh corresponds to a
sparse set instead of like uniforms and
overall
foreign
uh sorry pay I I don't know if um I'm
not hearing you well so is is there a
connection issue
foreign
is having trouble hearing him
can't hear you yet
you can do audio by phone if your
internet is unstable
I'm sorry uh Aaron
maybe he can connect audio he can dial
in for audio that's not too complicated
um could you do that uh instead
okay uh what about now can you hear me
much better yes yeah good okay okay okay
uh okay okay so so uh when you lost my
voice uh
so at the very beginning of this slide
okay okay good
uh yes so so even the one before
potentially over here
okay okay
yeah so uh we yeah so we we uh well so
for our like small set expansion
protocol we are left with the spiracy
test which in which we want to uh
uh determine whether our state is close
to a uniform superposition of some
subset uh s of the universe
and we also want to have some estimate
of the density or the sparsity of s
and this is the part where we actually
rely a lot on the
non-nactivity assumption
so like in particular what we will do is
we first prepare uh the uniform
superposition of everything
and also we asked many copies of like
the state site that's the state that's
the state we want to understand and also
uh like assistant
States and that is just a complement
version of it it's a superposition of
all the elements that's not containing s
and then what we will do is we were just
estimate
um the correlations between these three
states because we have many copies
constantly many copies of these states
so we can do this estimate
uh and then let's see what we should
expect so because
I and its complement like they are
support on different uh
bases so their correlation should be
zero and on the other hand
if you compare pesticide and like the
uniform superposition what you expect to
see
his uh it's like s over n
and here for plus I complement versus
the uniform superposition what
expectancy is like one minus
s Over N so like we expect the next two
Delta and beta add up to one
so these are the Criterion we want so uh
first these two uh are orthogonal and
then like when you compare with the
uniform superposition then the
correlation adds up to one
and now uh maybe let's just briefly see
why this help us to determine the
sparsity of our best state
well it is because that uh when percent
PSI complement are orthogonal
and uh
non-active uh amplitude case because
everything is positive
it actually tell tells us that the
percent is complement supports
essentially supports on a disjoint
subset of the computational basis
so let's say I want to support one
supports on S one supports are this
component
and then just apply cautious rewards uh
risk with respect to this restricted
supports and then we see that uh pasai
and its correlation with the uniform
superposition is maximized
when uh is actually a uniform
superposition on its support
and then you get a guess over n and on
the other hand it's same but you get
like one minus s over n
and as as we all know that uh question
inequality is saturated only when
you have a uniform uh scene therefore
when these two adds up to one it
actually tells us that they are both
uniform uh superpositions with respect
to their support
so is this the only place where you need
non-negativity in the whole in the whole
yes analysis wow okay cool thank you
okay thanks uh
yeah
um sorry sorry I'm not I'm not sure I
follow up something are you saying that
um
I see um you're you're saying that a bit
non-negativity even though orthogonal
you know the only way of functionality
can come about is through destroying
subsets on in the computational basis
because because you're saying
non-negative with respect to
computational basis
yes that's where the basis dependence
comes in and then then it goes through
this and okay okay
yeah
uh okay uh any any other questions
great so uh that's the small set
expansion problem and uh let's like
increase the harness a little bit look
at uh the unigam's problem
so maybe let me uh also like very
quickly uh refresh your mind about
what's unique games uh problem so it's
again some promise problem but for
Simplicity let's assume that we are
given a irregular graph key
and now for each Edge
there will be a bijection
um
that's some kind of constraints for this
instance and now we Define the value of
our graph to be
like the maximum fraction of the ages
that can be satisfied
over all possible labelings
like by by satisfying the constraints I
mean that the labels uh on the two
vertices do adjacent versus this should
satisfy this byjection map
okay and uh the unigam's problem here is
just uh the problem promise problem that
in the yes case the value of your graph
should be a large like uh
one minus Theta and in the no case in
the value of your graph should be uh
very very small close to zero like uh
like no matter how you label your
vertices like almost no edges can be
satisfied
okay
okay so now let's uh see how
uh
how we can design a qma first to
protocol for any camps so here now what
we would expect from learning
is the following a state so learning
will send us like encoding of how to
label this graph just by sending us a
uniform superposition over all the
vertices and together with the label
an author upon receiving uh
this proof what he will do is like here
again because we assume that this graph
instance is regular sorry this uh
picture is not regular
and then he or just take a random
permutation
and maybe uh this permutation where like
switch this blue vertex and this green
vertex and also switch this red vertex
and this blue vertex
and then after we apply this operation
here we're just the sand
[Music]
any state like a Vertex U to uh to
another state based on this permutation
so blue will be sent to ring vertex
and then change the label l
based on this bijection associated with
this h
so there will be a unique value for any
label l
and now notice that in the yes case so
if this unigam's instance is sorry can
you remind me what Fue was
nice so for every age unv
there is a bijection
yeah yes this projection like is the
constraints that we have oh right yeah
yeah
Yeah Yeah so basically here Here If U is
labeled by L then there is a unique
label for B to satisfy this H and that's
what we do
yeah uh yes okay so now in the yes case
so if uh like almost say almost all the
ages can be satisfied then when we do
this operation we are like we obtained
essentially the same state
because they should be consistent
uh
I can and then can the no case uh when
like only a small fraction of the edges
can be satisfied
uh where you do this operation like you
from like if these two edges are not
satisfied then when you send the label
to the unique satisfiable label you
actually get an inconsistent thing
therefore after this operation you get
something that's like a saga note to
your original state
so now just do the swap test and you
should be able to detect these two cases
with constant probability with the
constant Gap
well the uh but this horse needs to
assume that uh what standby earning
actually encodes a valid assignment
which is not necessarily the case so
we need some validity tests to ensure
that uh what standby murdering actually
give a valid assignment
of labels to the to other vertices
and once we do that we can show that the
unique games problem is content in qma
plus 2 using again only logarithmic size
proof who is a constant Gap
and maybe you know that there is this
version of unigam's a very uh seminal
result
that
we are comparing we are if we are
considering like a half versus
point zero zero one uh unicams then it
is MP hard to distinguish these two
cases
so this actually suffices for us to
already conclude that uh MP is
contending in our model with constant
Gap using only logarithmic size proof
any questions
yeah I have a question yeah
um is it necessary for you to have the
one-half versus like gamma
um hardness for Unique games or is any
consonant Gap there are fine for you
guys oh not any constant Gap so we need
some Gap I'm not sure what exactly the
Gap but uh we need some Gap I forget the
exact number okay okay
hey sorry I'm confused about something
like given this corollary why doesn't
this just solve the whole problem at
this point
um okay okay because like I want to
scale it up for to eventually I want to
prove like the next place is contending
oh I see so it's it's the scaling it up
by an exponential that remains to be
done
okay the other question was uh like uh
uh the the the this mapping uh uh T
we've got like T or t sub or so it
depends on a particular permutation so
then doesn't it have to be the case that
like the state gets mapped to itself for
every permutation
uh sorry uh uh so uh so so you you pick
a random
permutations uh in M sub R so yeah okay
and then uh the uh okay but it says then
the point is just that whatever the
permutation you know in the yes case
there is some Global assignment and now
the mapping is just going to be chosen
to be consistent all right I got it
thanks
and there's just a constant number of
the permutations I guess
uh yes
if yes yes it's uh we let's just we
assume like the regular graph is uh by
regular D regular D is a constant here
um
uh okay
uh yeah maybe uh
maybe let me skip to the relative test
part so it's basically based on sparsity
test uh
believe that if we can do sparsity test
then we can actually do validity test to
make sure that uh what we received from
the approver is actually a valid
assignment so are you using the fact
that these are constant here in the
validity test is that is that what it's
going to be
I only need to use the fact that I guess
the alphabet is constant and the
possible labeling is a constant right
that's where you'll do the hard Fourier
transformance
yes yes okay
yes so so anyway basically like if we
can do sparse test we can do validity
test
um okay and then maybe let's like go to
the constraint status action problem
um
the final part
of this talk
so so here like okay constraint
satisfaction problem uh for some
constant K is the following so on the
left side I I list all the constraints
and on the right hand side I list all
the variables
and each constraint will depend on K
variables they they are arbitrary
predicts they can do anything
and also like the the value of each
variable
um belongs to some constant size
alphabet
okay so now the question is just uh is
there a assignment that satisfies all
the constraints
and the famous PCP uh theorem tell us
that it is MP hard to distinguish the
case where like all the constraints can
be satisfied
or at most absolute fraction of the
constraints can be satisfied
and for now let's uh just think about
the MP version and later I was I would
say a bit more about the next p uh thing
okay so now let's uh say we have a
general case CSP instance and let's
design uh qma plus 2 protocol for a kcsp
instance
so now what we would want Merlin to send
is the following which asks the learning
to send uh uniform superposition of the
constraints
C1 to CN and then for each constraint
what follows is actually a list of the
values for the K variables that it
depends on
um like for C1 the vi1 correspond to the
value for X1 we have to correspond to
the value for X2 Etc
so this way of encoding is very
convenient if we want to just verify how
much fraction of the constraints are
satisfied like we just add an auxiliary
register and do the computation put the
results there and then measure this
auxiliary register
so this is a very convenient but we are
doing this without respecting the fact
that like this variable is used by
different constraints and Merlin can
send something like arbitrary without
respecting this fact
so author needs to have some
ways to uh enforce this consistency
and the way we are we do it is like
Express uh
uh implicitly
we think of a new a different uh CSP
instance by doing a regular
regularization step which is standard
in particular it's also used in original
famous PCP proof
so in particular let me uh say a little
bit more what happens here so we were
thinking that given this old CSP
instance
for each variable X
and here like I list X1 and that's all
the instances that's all the constraints
that uses X1
and then I will expand X1 into a cluster
of new variables
like each we create a new variable for
each constraint that uses X1
like this
and then we connect
these new variables
by expanded graph so if you don't know
expanded graph is just some irregular
graph that satisfies a very good
expansion property the expansion
property is just like the small stack
extension problem we defined previously
and this expansion property uh
actually help us to make sure that in
the soundness case if our original
instance has constant fractional
constraints that's not a set that's not
satisfiable than in the new uh larger
CSP instance the constraints uh there
are still constant fractional
constraints that not satisfiable
and in the yes case so if all the
constraints can be satisfied then
clearly what you are due when you
introduce a cluster of new variables is
just to assign the value for all the
variables
just agree with the original assignment
so okay so this is uh like a standby by
now a standard trick
okay so now let's see how we uh how we
enforce this consistency uh property
so in particular this is the state
beside is the state that we receive from
earning
and first we are going to
use this state to create the following
state so we
we for each constraint we list
the variables that's that's used by this
constraint I
and then based on the value
um
listed on this register for CI for the
constraints I we can also determine the
value
uh for this variable
so we obtain this state in some sense we
can view this state as a uniform
superposition over
the vertex the vertices
in the new CSP instance
and also like their value
x i j uh
okay and now we use
this property of the regular graph
so we apply a random permutation to
permute within each cluster
of each variable
so for example like this vertex which is
actually in the which is actually
indexed by the constraints and the
parable
it will be mapped to a new variable
which is which is indexed by a different
constraints
and these were the same variable
and also and also now now note that in
the yes case
uh so everything should be consistent so
they are the same and in the no case if
almost all the constraints are satisfied
then it must be the case that there is a
lot of inconsistency happening within
these purple edges
so when we do a swap test it will be
detected with high probability
okay uh
any questions so far
okay
so so now let me uh mention what what
happens if we want to scale this up
to next Pro so now we are looking for a
cfcsp instances that we obtained from uh
next by heart problem
and then what we should have is
exponentially large CSP
and when we to when we need to like uh
replace a variable with a cluster of
variables we need to use exponentially
large expander graph
so these expander graphs they need to be
uh very explicit
this is because when we apply when we do
this uh permutation
when we do this random permutation we
need to be able to using Quantum
polynomial time to decide even though
this is especially large expanded graph
which which permutation so so how the
how the verses rotates based on the
given permutation
and in addition like even if we know how
to uh decompose this expressly large
expanded graph
we also need to know for each variable J
for example like when we send this
constraint to this constraint what
exactly is the index for this constraint
so in the
uh in some sense we should be able to
like efficiently list
the constraint
for every variable uh in like a
polynomial Quantum polynomial time so we
we call this in fact we should be able
to we will be able to do it like
deterministic uh polynomial times
so we call this question
um
so in all this do you do you not have to
check that all the all the Clauses were
included and none were dropped you don't
have to do any such tests
yes yes I think I I didn't mention it
but that's kind of covered by the
validity test because here it's kind of
similar we uh like for each constraints
we have some kind of assignment it's
still like because it's constant number
of variables and each variable has
constant number of uh uh values so uh
this is also like uh as a as uh in all
it's also a constant sizing right so
yeah you can just use the Ability test
uh I mentioned to determine that yes
uh okay okay yeah so anyway so like in
conclusion what we need for the CSP is
um double explicit like originally we
know that from the constraint we can we
can efficiently know what are the
variables uses by these constraints but
now we also need like the other
direction from any variable we also want
to efficiently understand uh what
constraints uses this variable
um so that's like all we need
um to live these results to next
so uh uh in conclusion we show that next
is content in our new model uh using
Quantum massage
Quantum proofs with constant Gap
and there is an obvious other
inclusion that is this model is also
contained in next just for the same
reason as qma2 is containing next
um
I think that's all about that book uh
thank you listen
uh thank you very much babe that was
that was very nice um are there any any
immediate questions before we go into
the panel
maybe you could stop sharing okay
um
there's nothing then shall we
shall we start moving on to the panel uh
so
uh
okay so the panel today has um
as Scott Aronson who
you know I you know I I've decided that
uh for these for these panels I'll only
uh introduce Scott when we do not have
him on the panel because uh then I'll
try to justify why we did not include
him that particular time uh so in this
case I guess it was clear because
um you know the entire study of these uh
on entangle you know proof started with
a paper that's got wrote with um
Peter Shore and others so okay uh then
uh arm Harrow also everybody knows from
MIT uh I guess
um uh arams work on that pay mentioned
um uh you know really uh focused
attention on Q a too you know so
um and then
uh also Fernando uh
Geronimo he's he's also at is and a
quote on this paper so I wonder if he
can pin the in the videos or uh
it's for for the panel and uh maybe uh
let's let's go on to hearing comments
maybe start with Scott
yeah uh this was this was really nice I
mean maybe just to give a a little bit
of uh history here so uh uh I I remember
uh 20 years ago when uh uh qma2 was uh
defined it was for like nishimura and
yeah uh yamakawa maybe
uh
uh uh but uh um uh and you know I
thought that's a that's that's a strange
class like why would anyone you know
want to study such a thing right but uh
you know it was like completely bizarre
that the only upper bound that they
could put on it was the trivial one of
you know NX right like what you know
like surely that's just a technical
issue like surely if we put you know
when an hour of thought into it we could
improve that up orbound to uh uh you
know ax peace space you know something
right and then uh we uh circled back to
that question in uh 2007 actually uh uh
what happened was that you know that
that this question of what is the power
of qma2 it just kind of stuck with me
and uh I I I uh uh um when I when I
started as a faculty at MIT I mentioned
it to Peter Shore and then you know the
next day Peter came back with an idea
for you know here's how you might be
able to get a qma2 product or a a
protocol for three set that would
require only square root of N qubits and
then you know it took us a a month to
work out all the details of that but
that with that that ultimately worked
but you know we thought uh in the same
paper why don't we knock off this
problem of showing that qma2 was
contained in b space or something and
you know so we kept trying and and we
kept thinking we had it and then uh you
know it falling apart and and other
people have since had that same
experience and
you know I think in in the last few
years you know I I sort of
um you know like a few different things
uh one of them uh uh being you know uh
observations that that Aram uh made to
me uh about you know the connections
between uh uh uh unique games and and
and you know small set expansion and
qma2 and you know the fact that like a
certain kind of qm8 uh uh
um
you know there there are other kinds of
qma2 protocols where it looks like maybe
you could do NP with only logarithmic
size proofs with like a different
completeness soundness condition you
know but then also I saw the the MIP
star equals re right which was you know
a very analogous situation in a way
where you had this you know a Quantum
interactive proof class that had this
absolutely ridiculous upper bound you
know that was obviously not tight you
know and and we just had to solve the
technical problem of uh getting a better
upper bound but then you know after
years and years of effort it turns out
that we can finally explain why no one
could improve that trivial upper bound
and it's because that's the truth right
you know MIP star does go all the way up
to that ridiculous ceiling and so I
started thinking you know maybe the same
is true for qma2 maybe it actually
equals NX and I and I felt more and more
that way and then of course seeing this
work where qma plus 2 is equal to NX you
know has strongly reinforced that
conviction and especially seeing now you
know where the non-negativity is used
that it's really only used in this one
place you know to sort of show that for
the two sets the only way for two sets
to be orthogonal was for them to be uh
disjoint right uh and uh uh you know it
seems like uh uh that ought to be you
know you know you know it ought to be
like one more trick uh to to fix that
and I would be happy to hear during this
panel if uh uh uh pay and or Fernando
wanted to go into it so you know so like
what is the current status or what are
the difficulties in trying to uh uh show
that uh uh qma2 itself equals NX uh you
know I gather that it has something to
do with amplification I would I would
love to uh understand that
sure
so Fernando do you want to expand that
I've already I talked too much
yeah no we we can't right now you're
looking at qma2 right uh and we we saw
no negative amplitude characterization
of qma2
um if we start from qma plus two and the
Gap is sufficiently large a sufficiently
large constant that then this class
equals qma2 the usual so in a certain
sense you can use the usual geometry
protocol to to to decide the qma2 plus
but but you require a a fair large gap
in that case and so our our proof uses a
smaller it is
but and then our proof for foreign Gap
is it easy to see why qma plus two with
like a a suitable choice of Gap equals
qma2
without the Plus
if you want to say something it is it
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay okay so
basically uh basically like uh let's
let's just uh
let's just assume that let's say we have
a qma2 proof so like arbitrary State
just just suppose that we have an
arbitrary state to receive the frontal
earnings
and then you can always like uh find uh
you can just decompose it into like four
components the the imaginary part with
the positive thing the imaginary part
with negative seeing a real part with
positive thing real part with an active
thing so there are only four parts and
like one of them has to be correlated
with with the original state
um you like to like at least one or four
for example and then like if the
original protocol satisfies like a very
good components on this Gap then this
positive then one of the positive like
one of the parts without face would also
satisfy very good positive or very good
convenience on this requirement I see
but but how do you prevent the other
three parts from interfering with the
part that you want no no no no no I mean
like just the front and arbitrary
complex
um
a state that you can extract a
non-active state
and that serves as a good yeah but but
how do you I mean I mean I I could I
could see if you post select on one of
them but but it's not an observable I'm
not no no I'm not opposed to exactly let
me rephrase uh Scott's question which is
um
you know you kind of want to
completeness and sound it right so
you know if
um yeah you know to say like okay well
there is there is a non-negative state
that has good overlap with the general
state
um
no so maybe let me just explain it again
so yeah a little bit more yes I'm sorry
so let's say we have uh a qma to plus
protocol for next
with very very good uh completeness on
this Gap like Zero versus one for
example and now we were just using this
thing for a
well just use this exact measurement uh
for a general qma
to uh particle and our general and what
uh bad murdering will do he just send us
some
State uh General arbitrary complex State
no no the thing is if he can fool us
with very good probability then just to
extract that uh
non-active State and that state should
also be able to fool us with high
probability
like if the qma2 plus founded sorry
interrupt the qma2 plus down this is s
then the qma2 soundness is like order
square root of s or something like it's
it's it can't blow up
like if s is a very small number yes an
active sound is like the chance of
accepting a bad proof yes if this is a
number that's very small like close to
zero yes then
the the unrestricted proofs have a
soundness that is what order s or order
square root of s something like that
let's say it's uh this says S Plus
um like 0.99 for example five but that's
not possible but just because
yeah that's not possible just because uh
yeah yeah just because you have a large
uh non-negative state that correlates
with the general State and if you use
that state you can also full answer with
uh probably says uh plus like is plus
0.99 minus uh
this Trace distance which is some
constant
which will be greater than us
got it yeah
yeah so all the issue here is just to
show Gap implication for qma plus two
if we can do arbitrary application we
are done
so can you say more about yeah
what goes wrong with with uh
naive gas amplification is it just
yes so this is uh something that so so
like in your in your uh paper you show
like the swap test is uh uh it's like a
separable thing I mean I could actually
let me slow you down and you know the
only video is on the screen are people
who have been chewing I've been thinking
at qma issue on the brain not quite as
long as Scott but you know for a long
time but you know they're people in the
audience who have just heard about qmaq
for the first time today so so start
slower with what you mean by Gap
amplification you know why you're hard
yeah
uh okay so okay let me up yes so for
example we know like qma too we can do
Gap invocation meaning that if we have
some protocol with like completing this
on this Gap uh like a very tiny maybe
point zero then we can do some sort of
uh repetition to make this Gap as large
as say one
0.99 versus uh 0.0001
this is what I mean like by cap and
vacation
and uh in the case of qma plus two we
want to do the same thing but uh like we
don't know how to do it
yeah we know that parts of the Machinery
they work right that the product is
right yeah yeah there are two components
yes so part of uh the previous work uh
would do uh would do some job but uh we
cannot like uh do Gap application in all
the regimes
I think in in your paper here you have a
part that uh I don't know you first
repeat the protocol many times you bring
the completeness very close one it's
financially close to one that then you
do a product test right you go to two
proofs right uh and and and then you
should have some Gap but but you need to
repeat the protocol a few times right to
reduce the soundness at some point and
then you claim that that somehow that
you can implement the protocol as a
separable management and it allows you
to repeat the protocol quite a few times
right and this allows you to drag down
the sound that's right
the part up to the product test works
right you can amplify a lot the
completeness the completeness can go all
the way very close one or we can get a
constant Gap I don't know yeah but but
the product test also the soundness is
very large right uh even things are very
orthogonal right uh you should pay a
half or even more better so the the the
the the the the the soundness of the
product test already makes you lose
quite a bit it right it doesn't allow
you to go all the way to a sound that's
really small close to zero and then and
and then you do that and then you repeat
the the protocol several times right
yeah no the product test okay so it's
yeah it pushes your soundness above one
half by which you know meaning that
if you put in like if the answer is no
Merlin can still always trick you with
at least probability one half but then
when as you mentioned the the resulting
measurement become separable which means
let's say you have two provers and you
ask for K copies of your original proof
um and of course let's say they're like
the approvers are called Alice and Bob
and the Allison view A1 through AK and
Bob sends you B1 through BK are they
they allegedly K copies of the same
thing but they can try and cheat You by
entangling within the A's and entangling
within the B's
and then you're worried about
entanglement swapping like I measure A1
D1 and what if that induces entanglement
between the rest right and because it's
a separable measurement it avoids that
problem so A1 B1 by itself is separable
you measure it have it most you know
whatever probably two-thirds of whatever
some probability of fooling you and then
A2 B2 is again separable so it's sort of
a they have a fresh shot at it each time
and
and so then the soundness the chance of
of tricking you on a no instance goes
down exponentially with K so even though
with like the one copy found this okay
yeah that was above one half
you know you can then drive the
soundness down quite close to zero
um
you know by making use of the first the
product test and then the repetition
that's all in the case without the
non-negative amplitude so I would
so then yeah I guess I was wondering if
it was actually technical what
you know what's the part that goes wrong
when it is
in principle it can be violated right
and you lose that when you're right
things become separable you put in
principle repeat the protocol but but
now you're you have General amplitudes
appearing right out of that so maybe
yeah maybe of that saying it is like
so there's something
so yeah so maybe this is the question
that goes even Beyond qma2 a little bit
you know so let's say I have
you know I have systems a b c d right
and HDR entangled and and BC and sorry A
B are entangled and CD are entangled and
then I mentioned the middle two BC right
right right I can induce and take about
an A D and and that's entanglement
swapping right so what is the
so that you know that's interesting even
without any qma too
um right that that was exactly the
reason why naive amplification did not
work for qma right so I guess there
should be a phenomenon here that's
analogous right so what's the what's the
analog of attainment swapping for
non-negative amplitudes
I see we we haven't thought that much so
is it just again entanglement swapping
but just just that where it happens to
be with non-negative amplitudes
but I I actually I I I wanted to comment
the issue in a different way which is
that you know if you look at the Harrow
montanaro protocol from 2010 which
solved the problem of amplification for
ordinary qma too right like there has to
be some reason why that protocol would
not just immediately work in the setting
of qma plus two and in order for it not
to work there has to be something in
that in the verifier that would take a
state that is initially non-negative and
make it not non-negative right so which
aspect of the protocol does that
well they're just uh yeah the the
product has the swap test product the
swap test yeah yeah I see so so the
point is you can do the swap test with
two non-negative states but then after
you've done it you could be left with a
post measurement State that's no longer
not that good
is that is that the issue it must be the
other parts of the thing because
you know the swap test you project onto
the symmetric space so would that looks
like you take your initial the
superposition of your initial wave
function plus a partially flopped
version of that wave function right yeah
yeah so if the if the product
fails yeah that'll put into the minus
sign but but then you're already
rejecting
so it must be the other steps of the
protocol let me uh let me out let me
explain it uh again yeah so so now the
swap test is uh it's a use you can uh
you prove it so it's well known that it
is uh next separable uh state but uh
what happens is like uh you are uh it's
hard to say it's uh it's it's like uh
expected uh uh it's a projection onto
like expected uh uh random positions
rather orientations many directions
and when you apply this like like you
take a random uh maybe projections then
uh this thing like after after you do
this it's not necessarily the case that
what three minutes is non-active
um sorry I didn't quite understand uh
you're saying the swap test itself is
sorry what is this projection into
random directions
um so it's uh so a fact about uh swap
test is that it is projection onto uh
symmetric Subspace and the projection
into symmetric Subspace can be sync off
as
um the expected situation uh over like a
random uh projection onto uh
product uh States like uh but this
protects States corresponding to a
random Direction
um
including including non-uh
including negatives was complex yes yes
yes yes
but what what do you want to like to do
the parallel to do the repetition is
that after even take a random uh
permutation a random like projection uh
onto a random I don't know Direction
then what do you you have should be
uh non-active which is not necessarily
the case
that
this uh symmetric projector
you can decompose it
it's like you take your pick it's it's
either uh something with non-negative
amplitude that's entangled
or something that's separable with uh
complex amplitudes
yeah very
weird so so wait a minute can we State
what the bottom line is which step in
the in the verification vertical breaks
the non-negativity I think that there
may be many uh it's called any steps
many steps at this point because we have
some unit errors that they have the old
ones Vector right of the columns and
then they're going to have other vectors
that have negative signs as well I think
at this point there are many things so
the other parts of the verification they
also induce that but but even this
argument that had Target that product
that the product test is separable it
requires the composing a real
measurement in a way that's a complex
and has All Phase and science
I I I honestly had not remembered that
Harrow montanaro is this complicated
the hard part would be the product test
right the product test should be all the
difficult improving the soundness should
be an easy thing right we repeat the
protocol several times but in this case
it's uh but you also need to point out
that uh we we have it that there might
be room for something different in the
product test in the sense that uh uh
when you want to repeat the protocol
several times we can assume that what
you should expect several copies of the
same state so it's sort of a more
symmetric version of the product test
and you you do not want a guarantee
about the entire input right uh it's as
if you can run some tests in some part
of the state and if you could reduce
that uh I don't know the output of this
test is close to product we are also
good so it it seems that there is some
room to play right uh that we have you
can use stronger assumptions and you do
not want a full guarantee about the
input you can rely on something about
the output of some new symmetric product
is but so far we will have being able to
to explore that fully but it seems that
we are not a little in a slightly better
situation for the sequential the this
repetition of the protocol
um
thanks great so um did you remember did
you did you remember that your test was
that complicated
I guess I should maybe I should just to
clarify for the record uh Ashley and I
did not invent the product test our you
know our contribution was a sharper
analysis of it
um
and I actually forgot who invented it
but we definitely set them in our paper
um I guess the thing about the product
test is that it's uh
if your goal is just to be a separable
is just to be separable then then it's
easier it's um yeah the subtleties arise
when you add this non-negativity thing
which yeah which we certainly was not on
anybody's radar at the at the time
um
but it is
yeah this does open up a lot of rich
rich questions I guess I'll mention also
um
and maybe I want to ask so
non-negativity
in in the context of qma2
there was a um
but there was one paper that that
considered it was like was it Barack
kotari Sawyer
there was a
the the they have one of finding a ring
one uh Matrix in a Subspace right now
an SOS paper no um
so was there
um
I think it it required the the
completeness to be very close to one or
something like this
oh okay let me just ask so
as far as you're aware
of those not that we are aware of
yeah
um
we were trying to to play with those
protocols right and you're seeing that
when you're trying to understand support
right of course most expansion uh but
General amplitudes we couldn't do things
about the support for an inner products
right and then you saw the if things
were no negative then being your
orthogonal means that the supporters are
essentially disjoint so it is
trying to close the protocols right we
saw that with this condition it could
make the protocols work with constant
game
yeah I wonder
um
you know because I guess one
one question about these things is you
know what
what implications they have in for STP
hierarchies and uh
you know we
because
non-negativity is a constraint that can
can easily be imposed on on entries of a
matrix
um
yeah have you have you looked much at
the
um not that much about the the classical
part and all other things no
um
oh you know maybe what I'm thinking of
is there's a different question which is
okay yeah I realize what I'm thinking
about which is uh
you know human there are
two main two is very rich and and one
one nice set of variants of it is when
you restrict the measurements that
Arthur performs I mean so we talked
about how if the measurement is
separable then it allows amplification
and also how the product test means any
measurement can be reduced to the case
of separable measurements then if you go
beyond separable to like one-way locc
then you know this this appears to
really weaken the power right
um
and there's this uh you know this nice
paper by
um
and Tina Jang on uh
you know on the power of
uh qma2 with bell measurements
um and I remember now if you have a
measurement with yeah this is the case I
remember from before
if you have a measurement if your
measurement operator m
is so it's a measurement it should
always be positive then I definite but
if it's also entry-wide non-negative
then again it becomes classically easier
to simulate
um
and
I can't remember where I saw this it
actually may have may actually be
unpublished but
um this was definitely was yeah Boaz
Barack and Company
um
is this with counter
Kellner yeah oh you know yeah hey maybe
instead of kotari it was Kellner that
must be it yeah Barack Kellner or
someone else
um I do not know why I I think I vaguely
know it it becomes easier right yeah
yeah
um
that's right surrounding about
relaxation from 2013 Barack kellner's
doyer I'll put it in the chat
has um
you know in terms of this focus on kiami
2 is
is is there is there any study of QAM
too and and if not is it you know is
there a reason why q a 2 is is the right
object and it doesn't carry over to Here
I Am
yeah good question
uh Scott do you know
sorry what's the question you know the
question is um is has anybody studied
your
qam2 and if not is there a reason why
qma is the right class to focus on yeah
so so typically am classes are like the
the uh you know the the BP operator
adopt uh applied to the corresponding MA
classes right which means that like
under derandomization they collapse with
the MA classes right so like
QAM is equal to bp.qma for example and
under some strong enough d-reodinization
just is qma now um
um
you know I like the the uh uh the the
the most closely related thing that I
could think of is that uh I and Donna
moshkovitz and uh Russell and paliatso
had a paper about am2 right so so uh so
we studied it as a sort of model
situation for qma too okay because it
turns out that with with just am2 and
what we meant by that is that you have
two Merlins uh and you can send them
uncorrelated questions okay so you can
set let's say each Maryland can be sent
a a uniformly a different uniformly
random string okay uh uh independently
chosen strings and then they have to
respond to those and it turns out that
for am2 there is a protocol for three
set using only square root of n
communication okay just like there is
for qma2 and for much the same reason
okay it's uh can you can you so so
um you're saying somehow the unentangled
Nature's nature of the provers
uh translates into uncorrelated
questions even though exactly even
though in Q a 2 you can ask correlated
questions
to uh well in qma2 you don't ask
questions at all
so so you know it's not it's not obvious
that there should be any connection
between these sentences right yeah but
what turned out to be the case that
there is a protocol for three set in
this class am2 using square root of n
communication which is directly
analogous to the qma2 protocol that we
had given earlier okay and you know it
it uses the birthday Paradox right in in
much the same way and in that case in
that model situation we were able to
prove that that protocol is optimal you
know so so in other words doing three
set in am2 requires square root of n
communication under the exponential time
hypothesis okay now of course if it is
true that qma2 equals NX then that would
break the analogy
right that would show that that would
show that qma2 really is much more
powerful than am2 right am2 we should we
showed is ultimately just equal to
standard am uh albeit with a quadratic
blow up in the sizes of the proofs Okay
so
uh so so so so so so so so so so so so
so but but but but my point is that
already classically there was something
interesting to say about about am2 right
now uh QAM too uh you could study that I
guess there would be different ways of
even defining it right like what are the
questions that you're you know I mean I
mean I mean once you have like
uncorrelated questions to the two
separated provers then you might as well
just be talking about MIP
no no but but uh do you need to have
uncorrelated questions I mean once you
have unentangle approvers you could ask
correlated questions to them well right
right questions right uh right but okay
but then you know oh yeah so sorry sorry
when the questions are correlated I mean
that's the case where you would have MIP
right uh
you know it's it's I mean I mean I mean
the the distinction that we made why
would you have them I okay well I uh I
mean I mean oh you're saying you're
saying because because you're not now
you're gonna additionally assume that
the provers are are not entangled yeah
yeah absolutely I say I say so they're
not intent
um okay that's Andrew I mean I I
remember that uh uh uh you know in the
original Nisha Mora paper like 20 years
ago where they defined qma2 they they
also considered the this this variant
like Quantum you know they studied qmip
and also qmip where there is no
entanglement between the the approverts
right and you know and and the thought
uh at the time was was that like that
might be uh uh you know you might in
order to do something powerful you might
have to assume no entanglement right you
know I think that you know people were
not thinking what turned out to be true
that you get this extraordinary power if
you do have entanglement
just to add a little context for all the
the people who might be bewildered by
all the the range of options here
let me yeah let me just give my take on
on this area which is I quite like qma2
with log size Proverbs I find that sorry
a lot of size proofs
um
because that takes away actually I mean
there are things are interesting in
different ways and but I just want to
like mention this
if you have q a with log tax proof
you're just trying to this is just
trying to find the maximum eigenvalue
right which we we know you can do in
time polynomial to dimension
and then the corresponding problem for
qma2 is well it's NP hard to get it
exactly and there's sort of weaker NP
hardnesses if you want to get it get it
approximately uh for depending on your
your level of approximation
um and what's interesting about this is
it it turns it there's a convex
optimization problem here which is
interesting
and you no longer have to worry about
the measurement circuit
you know because these things are only
login log log in qubit
if in polynomial time you can do any
possible measurements right so that's
that part is kind of taken away
um so you could say for example for
ordinary qma what's interesting about
the class is not the finding the largest
eigenvalue part right that's the but but
the the fact that the class of
measurements you can do is generated by
a polynomial time Quantum circuit uh and
so when you scale down to a log size
the the circuit complexity is taken away
and you've just you just have the the
convex optimization problem of finding
the large eigenvalue and then with the
qma2 part you it's a different convex
optimization problem which turned out to
be pretty interesting for qma2 plus is
to get a different one which which is
also interesting and I wonder what qma2
with log size proofs
you know this must be
you know yet another
again another problem where circuit
complexity no longer plays into it it's
just some you know some problem of I
don't know Norms of quantum channels or
something like that
um
and so I guess if I were to think about
qma2 sorry q a M2
it might be interesting to start there
it's like is there what what is this the
logs the log proof version look like
um
is there anything where you can just
Define it without even bringing in
uh
you know circuit side
that's like a simple version
right
thanks um yeah thanks um
so um let's see uh any any other
thoughts before we
look let's potentially uh it is
mentioned what they believed in the
beginning and how we switched to
believing that potentially coming to may
be equal to next what about you
[Music]
um
what do you what's your guess or your
feelings about the complexity of 2002 oh
yeah or how it evolved for you
over time yeah
I don't know yeah
and what crucially breaks with separable
measurements why I imagine that you
might have tried to apply convex sum of
squares powerful convex higher it is
using this special structure of this
measurement being separable
why I don't know with that was elusive
to to get something better out of that
[Music]
yeah so this you know this gives upper
bounds for qma too
when you have various restricted
measurement families
but not for uh
not for General measurement
is there any crucial intuition as to why
things break down right you mentioned
that for one way also see it does right
they have those absolute net arguments
and so on right there yeah I mean you
know here's one way to think about this
which is
um
the different measurement families
induce different Norms on your States
right so you can think of like the trace
Norm is how distinguishable are these
two states row and sigma if you're
allowed to use unrestricted measurements
to distinguish them and then
it turns out if you're allowed several
measurements to distinguish them that's
pretty close to as good as general
measurements
but if you're allowed only one lfcc
measurement that's quite a bit weaker
and
you know there are sometimes these giant
gaps for these data hiding States
um and so you know I find that helpful
because now you're just thinking about
it as the problem of as I was saying
it's sort of like a convex optimization
problem it's not a it's not anymore a
question about the circuit complexity
you get gets de-emphasized
um
and so
yeah so when thinking about like the
general qma2 puzzle the fact that when
you have a
down measurement or one LLC measurement
to get quite a bit weaker
uh how should that shape our thing about
the general problem well you know those
those types of measurements are really
quite different and
uh it could very reasonably be that that
one loc measurements are are very
different than General measurements and
knowing about one doesn't
one doesn't reduce to the other one
um so you know at first I thought oh
we've cracked the one LCC case we just
have to push that up to separable but
you know now I I've come to believe that
they're they're allowed to be very
different
um
and then
yeah how powerful is to make like could
qma2 be in P space or should it be NX
um
yeah to be seen right though I yeah I
don't know I mean I wouldn't be
surprised before NX especially your
result makes that feel a lot closer
um but there is quite literally a gap
right now a constant gap between this
yeah I mean I mean I mean come on it's
hanging by a
fingernails
but it needs more research right then
the things you know they keep surprising
us so I wouldn't
I wouldn't be surprised like I would
love to read any of the outcomes I
wouldn't I wouldn't bet against any of
them
um
do we have a bet
I mean I think and I could more likely
than anything else because
I can't I can't draw the like
your paper gives a reason why Annex is
plausible
I don't think anyone's given a reason
why P space should be the right answer
I'll put a thousand on NX but if someone
wants to take the other side of that
but you know I mean in practice you'd
only refute that belief by like putting
in Upper bounds of X for p space so you
know that even yeah even if our first
night is right that might be hard to do
the thing about your bet Scott is you
just say look you know I pay a thousand
dollars just to see a proof it's not an
X just because that would be the most
interesting group at this point a proof
that it is NX would be the least
interesting one so it makes it a very
safe bet
yeah yeah you have to give odds um Scott
you can't just not just the amount
oh well I mean I I was I was uh uh
assuming uh it would it would be an even
bet if someone oh my goodness someone
wants to propose an uneven one then I'll
I'll I'll I'll I'll I'll I'll I'll
consider it when I hear it what about
look wouldn't you just pay a thousand
dollars for not equal maybe if you maybe
you don't care about the problem this
much I mean I mean yes but I don't want
to make a general policy of it yeah yeah
you know this way it doesn't make a
statement right
I mean you think I'm made of money like
okay
all right great uh well this was this
was most fun thanks uh Scott and uh
there was there was very fun and thank
you for a great great talk and and uh
also okay Fernando for being so sporting
to talk about stuff that you're
currently thinking about and that's
that's really nice here and uh this was
this was really great session
thank you so much
thank you thank you
all right thanks bye bye everyone see
you next week